brady i'm actually going to talk about
uh the thermionic valve but
everybody recognizes a valve like this
they might find on their plumbing system
at home as if the valve is closed then
no water flows and
if it's open then i can
can see through it and if it's half open
then only half the flow
goes through and of course what will be
really nice is to be able to have an
electronic version of that if we think
about what was happening a hundred years
ago or just over 100 years ago the age
of electrical world if you like
obviously motors were around
lamp bulbs and so on we could switch
them on and off but we couldn't control
the amount of electricity going through
them uh easily somebody like edison who
would uh who would obviously building
lamp bulbs he
was quite intrigued as to why his lamp
bulb was going black on one side and not
on the other something strange was
happening inside the actual device
itself and point of fact what it was was
carbon atoms were actually heading
towards one side of the
filament if you like the very first
particle
accelerator and of course people like jj
thompson took those ideas on and started
to try and investigate where
what were these mysterious particles and
and rays and so on one of the early
experiments was something called the
maltese cross experiment
and i've got one of those uh just here
if you can can see this one this is a
modern version of the maltese cross
experiment but
clearly it's it's almost identical to
the original we can see
an anode
just in there it's made out of metal
and it's powered by a high voltage which
is coming from the from the power supply
we also have a cathode
we eventually find out that the the
actual rays that are coming from the
cathode so called cathode rays are
indeed electrons and of course that's
the breakthrough that uh jj thompson
made so what's what's going on i think
we probably need the the light off if
you can manage that ready yeah
we can't see the the cathode directly
but we can see the light that's given
off by the cathode but what's happening
is the electrons are boiling off and
they're being accelerated by the
electric field towards the towards the
anode now if we're very careful we can
turn up the high tension supply and now
we can uh we can see
the
the green glow the phosphorescence
of which is caused by the high-speed
electrons
well we're seeing the ones that have
missed the target and are hitting the uh
hitting the phosphor we get a shadow of
that uh
of that cross
why it's called the maltese cross
experiment why they put a maltese cross
in the first place we don't uh we don't
really know another little interesting
thing that
we discover is that if i take a little
magnet
and point it towards
the beam
then the magnet deflects the electrons
in the beam remember that these devices
become the forerunners of things like
the cathode ray tube which used to be in
televisions until a few years ago where
we actually use the magnetic field to
deflect the uh the electron beam and
cause a spot to travel about on the on
the phosphor thus making our
our picture okay well we've got to we've
got to come forward a few years and and
think about um
a chap called john ambrose fleming who
was in point of fact the very first
professor of physics in 1881 um
here at nottingham however he only
stayed one year he went off to
do other things like
invent the thermionic diode
what he discovered was that
he could make a device which only
conducted electricity one way because if
i connected the anode and cathode around
the wrong way then we wouldn't get
anything
so current only flows through this
device in one in one direction what was
even more useful it was something that
uh chap called the deforest came up with
in 1906. i've got a nice little diagram
of
of a thermionic diode on the on the
board already written we can see the the
filament we can see the cathode we can
see the anode what leader forest did was
put in
an extra
so-called control grid as he called it
and by controlling the voltage
we'll call it
controlling the voltage on that uh input
there
he could he found that he could control
the current that was flowing through uh
through the diode in fact the important
thing is a very small change in the
voltage
produces a large change in current we
have an active device which will
increase the power of a signal and so
that really is the vital breakthrough so
obviously we connect the heater up to a
to a voltage
and this heats up the the cathode and
what would happen is that the electrons
jump out of the surface of that
of that heated heated metal but
obviously soon returned to it if we
apply an anode voltage a large anode
voltage then these electrons get swept
up
along
and towards uh towards the anode so
hence the flow of the electrons is
always towards the the higher voltage
however notice that the current flow
i
is conventionally in the opposite
direction it's one of the things our
forefathers got wrong uh in a sense
which has confused
um confused us ever since really is that
they the electron flow is opposing the
actual conventional current flow if we
put a voltage on our on our input that
disturbs the electric field
caused by
this
anode to cathode
field and effectively what what happens
now instead of the electrons flowing
flowing up they get they get stopped
and and obviously fall back uh and so on
so we can control that if we look at
what a real
valve is this is a this is a this is
quite a quite a meaty one
but this this device itself um would be
used as a radio transmitter valve and in
point of fact uh
something like this is uh is still in
use because
although
valves were superseded by um solid-state
devices from about the 1960s
and so on onwards and a transmitting
valve like this is still the most
efficient uh
efficient and cost-effective way of
of transmitting so even in our mri
scanner 3t
current mri scanner we actually have a
valve amplifier um because it's the only
way you can cost effectively get 25
kilowatts of rf power well the glass is
is is of course there to keep the vacuum
in so inside we have a complete vacuum
and it's the vacuum is sucked out
through this and sealed through that
little uh little spigot and it has to be
that big because of course it gets very
hot and so we need to conduct the um
heat away why the vacuum because if we
have if we had
if we have anything in
air molecules in inside there then the
electrons will will scatter off
and uh we won't get uh we won't get any
any flow at all there are still people
around who who swear by valves
particularly audiophiles they love to to
use valve amplifiers and although this
is a little bit more of an antique
device down here again if you switch the
lights off
brady let's do that
you can see the the valves glowing uh
glowing away and these these are
amplifying valves at this end and then
this is the output stage valves and this
is actually the
rectifier diode
being used to rectify the power supply
this is uh this is an audio amplifier so
connect it to a loudspeaker and feed it
with a signal from your record player
and you will get sound out